l'histoire que nous allons vous raconter
commence peut-être ici sur l'ex
nationale 138 à gauche andré loire
plaque 37 à droite le département de la
sarthe 72
c'est une frontière administrative mais
aussi peut-être celle d'une guerre
intestine d'une guerre froide ou chaude
entre deux jumelles voici l'histoire de
la guerre des lignes est entre tours et
le mans
connerré dans la sarthe
c'est ici dans les années 1900 que la
rillette sarthoise pris son envol
albert lhuissier charcutier de riom a eu
l'idée géniale de se rendre à la gare du
village pour proposer ses rillettes aux
voyageurs du paris nantes obligé
d'observer une escale de deux heures le
voyageur se régala et albert fier envoya
par la suite des caisses de peau de la
délicieuse préparation en direction de
la capitale
ce fut le début d'une incroyable
réussite
[Musique]
mais c'est surtout le circuit des 24
heures du mans qui fera connaître cette
rillettes
dès les années 30 tout les buvettes
proposait alors cette spécialité locale
entre deux tranches de pain que les
passionnés de sport automobile déguster
entre deux bolides en 1971 une porsche
dit le cochon rose rendra hommage au riz
à connerré on dit que l'arrière du mans
ou sarthois serait une copie
attention sujet sensible et sur ce point
délicat les établissements unis n'ont
pas souhaité s'exprimer mais sur l'art y
est le connais rien et atari st
la bei à connerré au départ c'était la
fabrication des rillettes à la et alors
ce triet les bonnes délicieuse ah oui
elle est meilleure que celle de touraine
c'est pas du tout pareil c'est pas du
tout les mêmes mais n'ont pas la même
conception
je me suis habité et connerré oui je
suis né j'ai habité en touraine donc
j'ai pu discuter et goûter à ses
rillettes
elles n'ont pas le même parfum et la
meilleure c'est c'est celle d'ici ah bah
tiens je vous le fais pas dire non je
suis pas chauvin simplement réaliste
bon allons voir en touraine et nous
voici au coeur de la préparation des
fillettes à villedômer c'est le père
chante un charcutier de père en fils
invitons donc d'abord sur le chemin de
la recette
nous avons sélectionné un port qui
s'appelle le roi rose layette de toury
gp nous sommes
obligé de faire avec ce port de touraine
qui s'appelle le roi rose donc là on est
en train de préparer le début de la
recette on découpe le jambon ces quatre
partis du genre là vous avez le jambes
le jambon complet dans la recette vous
aurez 25 kg de jambon 25 kg des pôles 40
kg de petits maigre et le reste c'est de
la panne bras il est vrai que lee gp
indication géographique protégée obtenu
en 2013 à booster quelque peu la
réputation de la rillette de tours
fabriqué uniquement avec des ports
locaux élevés à la graine de lin hsin
vite et on met toute la recette dans la
marmite et on reste la viande pendant à
peu près une heure c'est la différence
avec d'autres y est ça peut démarrer
comme ça parce que il épuise alors nous
on qu'une oreillette vous voyez qu'il ya
pas de couverts par rapport à ce qu'on
peut trouver dans la sarthe
il est cuit à l'étouffée donc non les
ferries solaire il se l'est longtemps
alors que il met tout il court est bien
ou mal après la première partie c'est le
risque l'âge de notre viande et les
rillettes ne seront jamais couverte de
toute leur puissance
et voilà c'est là le secret de l'arrière
de touques qui va lui donner ce qu'ils
me jeter cet aspect si particulier
tirant sur le brun à cela ajoutez une
louche de 20 de montlouis ou de vouvray
mais écoutez bien il ya un plus on
rajoute à la différence de l'arrière de
la salle de la rue ce qu'on appelle la
renault 4l
c'est une réduction d'oignons donc on
rajoute un petit peu dans la recette est
ce qui leur donne encore un goût
différents un petit peu et qui lui qui
l'a colorise encore un petit peu plus
ensuite elle sera mise en pot
mécaniquement ou à la cuillère selon le
marché avant de partir qu'elle ne fut
pas notre surprise devant cette marmite
mais c'est de la sarthoise où je rêve ça
c'est les rillettes du mans n'a le droit
départements voisins nous avons
l'appellation rayonnement aussi et donc
son oreillette du mans au jambon que
l'on fabrique et qui ont été médaillées
d'or à paris dernière ah oui ingérence
territoriale trahison aux batailles de
médaille même si c'est le début d'une
nouvelle histoire pour les rillettes de
tours grâce à son nouveau label de
l'histoire est beaucoup plus ancien
c'est en 480 qu'il faut remonter pour
les voir déguster lors de ripailles et
le meilleur ambassadeur fut rabelais en
l'appelant labrune confiture de cochon
facile à tartiner sur une tranche de
pain puis ronsard balzac et même même le
fragile marcel proust en firent l'éloge
de nos jours au corps des auteurs
s'enflamme pour elle comme jean marie
laclavetine
il ya un moment où il faut dire la
vérité et s'il est certaine la disparue
frappe les tourangeaux eux disent les
rillettes du mans comparer à celle de
tours ne valent pas tripette
c'est la vie c'est la réalité
vous prenez une rillettes du mans elle
est toute pâle tout effiloché et stagne
dans un bain de saintdo triste et sans
âme vous regardez la rillette de tours
aussitôt la vie arrive la vie est là
elle et elle est doré les fondus dans un
jus de vouvray elle présente ses
morceaux de viande affriolantes brune
doré mordoré il n'y a pas de comparaison
possible
bon aller retour au mans aux abords de
la place de la république
c'est clair chez le sarthois il y à du
chauvinisme plus que d'objectivité
culinaire est sans doute une pincée de
mauvaises four préférant se vend aux
rillettes du mans ou rillettes de tours
rillettes du mans par principe je range
pas beaucoup d'humain pourquoi
c'est les meilleures rillettes de tours
oui j'ai jamais goûté aux rillettes de
tours vous connaissez pas non je connais
mary had you man oui et il ya de tout je
connais pas bien sûr on l'a très bonne
riez de tours mais l'excellent trio du
pente bonne question je sais que les
rillettes viennent à l'origine de tours
mais étant dûment je vais dire les
rillettes du mans et plus
particulièrement de connerré à ce que le
régime quoi ce qu'on dit souvent c'est
les riads de connerré pas forcément du
monde donc moi je dirais les rillettes
de connerré pas du monde victoire
très bien même exercice rue nationale à
tous vérifions les réponses avec la même
question est la même mauvaise foi des
plus de morceaux est ce que j'aime
pourquoi pas parce qu'elles sont
meilleures
de même deux tours tout pourquoi au
niveau du goût
il ya du mans jument selle à tour
pourquoi parce que je fais chauvine
non pas du tout et je les préfère
pourquoi le goût
elles sont moins grasse vont pas être
contents quand ils vont savoir forcément
pourquoi parce qu'elles sont moins
grasse est le plus épicé
suite
les savoureuses
c'est orange a dit comme ça en moselle
évidemment bon reprenons question la
guerre de rillettes serait-elle
uniquement dans les esprits retour au
mans et nous voici chez comme ici un
départ que dans le cochon tout est bon
mais cela dépend du cochon suivant cette
fois ci la préparation de la mancelle
sélection des morceaux d'abord
on a sélectionné quelques morceaux comme
les filets mignons les filets 1 les
échines et là il reste les jambons les
épaules les pointes quelques poitrine et
on fait un bon mélange de façon des
pièces nobles de façon de faire quelque
chose où il reste des gros morceaux à
l'intérieur et maintenant la cuisson et
c'est là la différence car cette cuisson
se fait un couvercle fermé à l'étuvée et
non à l'air libre comme en touraine ont
fait résonner le grand au départ de
façon de monter en température quand on
est à 96 80 18 degrés
le drive bien chaud on va incorporer
petit à petit c'est le maigre de façon
dû donner à la fois la couleur et le
bout et là vous allez refermer un moment
et laisser cuire en même temps alors là
cette cuisson rapide de ris l'âge donc
là on en a pour une heure une heure et
demie ensuite on va régler le feu de
façon de ne pas aller trop vite
et là on va attaquer toute la nuit pour
une douzaine d'heures de cuisson long
mais pour joël comme le mancelle est
aussi un produit authentique et très
anciens alors il polémique avec humour
sur le sujet il ya une polémique sur
l'origine du produit
mais après bon il ya eu des choses qui
se sont fait qu'ils ne sont pas écrites
non plus hein c'est vrai que sur la
touraine on a souvent parlé de rabelais
qui parlait dans ses livres de la
rillette
nous n'avez peut-être pas d'écrivain
cette époque là est peut-être qu'on
fabriquait déjà des rillettes aussi et
toc
alerté par notre présence le grand
maître de la confrérie sarthoise est
venue nous rendre une petite visite pour
signer un traité de paix officiel
quoique que la force soit avec lui et
veut pas dire que c'est une concurrence
puisque ont fait pas le même produit de
deux charcutiers qui font les mêmes
rillettes peuvent se considérer comme
concurrent parce qu'ils sont sur le même
produit sur le même marché
nous les rillettes sarthoises ont leurs
qualités ils sont reconnus nationalement
les mêmes à l'inde
à l'étranger on en a fabriqué jusqu'au
québec est par contre les rillettes de
tours ont leurs qualités aussi elles
sont faites pour les gens de touraine
mais pour nous ça change ça change rien
bon bah voilà c'est pas les mêmes retour
surtout la rillette graspa grâce avec
morceaux ou pas pas facile de s'y
reconnaître nous avons pour notre
enquête organisé une dégustation à
l'aveuglé avec quatre candidats venus de
régions diverses dans leur assiette
rillettes du mans ou deux tours à eux de
trancher dans l'oreillette deux tours
pour moi c'est une bonne réponse
oui c'est ça je confirme rillettes de
tours annoncé perdu là je pense que ce
sont des rillettes de touraba c'est
encore perdu pour moi rillettes de tours
et voilà une bonne réponse dans
l'assiette
pas si facile finalement maintenant
rendons-nous chez un médaillé de la
rillette de torah champion toutes
catégories qui affiche un certain parti
pris il est aussi labellisé gp sa
préparation on répond à un cahier des
charges bien précis
ils ne sont pas très nombreux en
touraine posséder et il participe à de
nombreux concours son secret à lui c'est
le taux de cuisson on l'a fait qu'une
dizaine d'heures c'est presque au dessus
de la moyenne 6 8 heures ou non se
dépenser ça dépend à quelle température
de pose en fait on l'a fait mais plus ça
cuit mais hier c'est en fait dans votre
carrière vous avez fait darier de la
sorte un jour
non je pense pas non c'est vrai je ne
sais pas faire l'arrivée de gaza j'ai
jamais appris faire l'arrière-salle
peut-être après l'émission juste serait
peut-être j'aurais changé peut-être pas
sûr
peut-être que c'est ceux du mot qui
seront faire là il faut peut-être comme
nous l'a aussi messages sont venus nous
rendre visite et finalement à les
entendre cette guerre des rillettes ne
serait qu'une légende tentative
d'explication
c'est parler tous la main fabrication
pas le même produit donc bâchée ils font
leurs ils font leurs rillettes d'un côté
et nous on fait notre rillettes de
l'autre et puis voilà et avec la
confrérie on s'entend très bien il ya
plein de problèmes
bon ben voilà c'est pas les mêmes et
puis c'est tout assoiffés de savoir
servait luçon on y trouvera des idées de
recettes car l'arrière du monde tour se
cuisine aussi pour des entremets des
amuse-gueules finalement le coeur des
rillettes n'aura pas lieu
mais force est de reconnaître que dans
cette histoire une mère cochon n'y
retrouverait pas ses petits
le temps passant les soeurs jumelles se
rapprocheront doucement l'une de l'autre
et pour calmer le jeu sachez que des
premières grief fait leur apparition
dans la rome antique alors bon peut-être
qu'un jour elles se retrouveront à
l'unisson comme un ventre deux tranches
de pain dans une sorte de sandwich
moderne qui lui connaît une carrière
internationale
[Musique]